so we've Netflix about to dive into the
witcher universe i have no idea if it's
gonna be great or absolutely terrible
but those who haven't read the books or
played the games may have some questions
before watching the show the most
obvious being what is a witcher before
we delve any further into that
explanation it's important to note that
there are some differences between the
books and the games and it's likely this
will be the case for the show this is
relevant because in Andrzej Sapkowski x'
original books a witcher is referred to
as a via German which surpass key then
translated as a hexa the term Witcher
only became the established translation
when CD Projekt RED adapted these books
into games since then sap ASCII has used
the term Witcher and honestly The
Witcher sounds much more catchy than the
hexa somewhat sets these witches apart
from normal folk how does one become a
Witcher and how are they able to slay
these supernatural creatures and
monsters when the first humans arrived
in the continent in the area that we now
call tomb area these harsh lands were
unforgiving and filled of new threats
they would have to defend themselves
from this task fell to a group of
warrior monks the very first witches who
would use the surrounding environment to
enhance their own abilities and mutate
and transform themselves into beings
capable of fending off this new world's
monsters the process involved a mixture
of mutagenic mushrooms herbs and plant
stimulants it would later be refined
into much more of a science but this
granted them supernatural abilities and
powers that would even the playing field
allowing them to hunt creatures and
monsters that were used to being the
ones doing the hunting it's at this
point in time the demand for witches was
at its highest the process of becoming
one starts as a child very few children
were ever selected but those who did
demonstrate potential would undergo
trials at selected keep sandcastles no
as witcher schools care moyen being one
of the most famous mentioned in the
books as well as one that you can
explore in the witcher 3 these witcher
schools took their names from animals
and you can tell which school witcher
belongs to by the medallion they where
witches from other schools do appear but
this is further expanded upon by the
games where you have schools belonging
to the cat Gryphon Viper bear crane and
Manticore each of them is located in a
different area with a different focus
so a witch's training is never quite the
same
children chosen by these schools would
go through an intense and grueling
process known as the trial of the
grasses this involved ingest in those
same mutagenic compounds that the
original witches discovered all those
years ago it said that less than a third
survived the trial of the grasses and
the rest died an extremely painful death
so if you consider the fact that only a
few are chosen to be witches and only a
third of those even make it past the
apprentice stage it explains why they
are somewhat of a rarity those lucky
enough to survive or essentially mutants
bred for the purpose of hunting these
monsters their entire physiology changes
they now have enhanced speed strength
reflexes and endurance which allows them
to chase and kill creatures non witches
wouldn't stand a chance against their
wounds heal at an accelerated rate and
their boosted immune system makes them
immune to most forms of disease this
also accommodates for the large amount
of potions they consume allowing them to
augment their own abilities without fear
of a chemical overdose these potions
sent them into a trance or frenzy during
combat allowing them to ignore pain and
continue fighting even if severely
wounded changes to their sensory system
means they can identify and track what
creature they're hunting by the mere
scent of their blood the most iconic of
these sensory mutations are the cat-like
eyes which allow them to see in extreme
light and darkness
another side effect of this mutation is
an extended lifespan allowing witches to
live for centuries in some cases while
still maintaining a youthful appearance
so if witches can live for so long it's
not unreasonable to ask why they don't
just breed a bunch and pass these traits
down to their children removing the need
for the trial of the grasses in the
first place
well that's not really an option the
entire process of becoming a Witcher
makes them sterile so they need to
select children from the outside to
undergo these trials another side effect
that comes from the trial of the grasses
is a stunt in their emotional growth
many consider witches as emotionless
monsters unable to feel empathy but we
see enough from Geralt especially in the
games to suggest that this may not be
true from a very young age these
children are taught to control their
emotions if you also consider that they
are trained to be cold-blooded killers
who have seen an experienced Horrors
normal folk could only imagine being
able to detach yourself emotionally
seems to be the only way to remain sane
it also makes it easier to deal with
humans refusing to pay for their service
I think it's more of a case of witches
choosing not to show emotion because
remaining calculated and disciplined is
what keeps them alive it also may be
interpreted as a sign of weakness which
they are certainly not it really just
depends on the individual magic itself
plays a fairly large part in the witcher
universe casting these spells often
requires an in-depth knowledge of their
magical formula this isn't really a
witches area of expertise nor is it
practical in combat instead they adapted
these spells of the use of magical signs
this means they can cast simple spells
by mimicking the sign of their fingers
allowing them to cast a spell in the
middle of combat of one hand and still
wield a weapon with the other they may
not be spells as powerful as you may
expect from a mage or a sorcerer but
signs are quick require little
concentration and provide witches with
another trick up their sleeve these
signs can be anything from a telekinetic
wave and
that offer protection to trap sudden
snare foes and a gush of flames that
incinerates enemies but even with all
these physical mutations and the use of
magic they still required extensive
weapon training and there is one weapon
that every Witcher can turn to their
sword or in this case swords as many
prefer to carry around - a sword made of
silver to cut through the supernatural
and they sword made of steel to deal
with any human issues despite being
human witches were often seen as
outcomes and some of this comes down to
fear of what they were capable of in
order to hunt and kill monsters they had
to transform themselves into something
that many labeled as non-human it
creates a dynamic whether people need
the witches but there's always that fear
that when the monsters are gone they'll
be left of the ones they created
themselves and this idea of a lack of
emotion and empathy only further
perpetuates this fear with the threats
the humans diminishing over the years
the need for witches was also greatly
reduced
however this meant attentions then
turned to the witches who along with
their schools were attacked by those who
opposed the use of magic to summarize
witches are essentially mutated super
soldiers or Monster Hunters it may be a
dangerous and thankless job but someone
has to do it as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained
[Music]